the notion of what constitutes adequate
sharing has always been a problem I mean
that's not an American issue that we're
talking about Galileo and Newton a issue
here you know communities individuals
and communities have understandably
different notions about what's what they
wish to share and what they don't wish
to share this goes right back to playing
in the sandbox you know in now in
science we have the cultural phenomenon
of peer review and that begs two
questions what's appear and what's being
reviewed it's not enough if you're if
you're a sophisticated scientist or
frankly a sophisticated person it's not
enough to review the data you know what
goes in and what goes out you want to
see the machine you want to see the
nature of the experiments you want to
see the code now with digital stuff you
want to see the code the software was a
biased in any sort of way was there a
bug that might account for some of the
phenomena that we're observing so
there's a real tension here between what
constitutes effective sharing and what
constitutes the desire that many people
have to have to make their science their
science to make their research their
research not in a proprietary ownership
sense but in the sense of you know ah
it's a little too soon for me to
completely open the kimono the
complicating factor just to build on
that is when you begin to inject market
forces when you begin to inject
political forces climate change should I
patent this finding do I want to license
this to somebody will give me lots of
money to do research you've now created
a mix of motivations and incentives does
it make more sense for me as a scientist
to share my methodology to show people
how good my work is and to get to get
credit for my peers or does it make more
sense for me to make some of its secret
so that i can get private funding to
continue the research along our route
that i consider very good
important I mean it is a it is it is
amazing I'm a child of an academic a
child of a science academic and it is a
I grew up in a in a very very elite a
research university environment and I am
astonished by what scientists are
capable of getting away with even
prestigious scientists are capable of
getting away with in terms of
withholding and sharing things the ideal
the Platonic ideal is that you know it's
like a let's create a nice phrase here
it's like a kibbutz and everybody shares
that science is a form of socialism and
everybody shares the results and
everybody shares their instruments and
to a certain extent large parts of that
are true but they're very large parts
where it's seventy to eighty percent
accurate and in that missing twenty to
thirty percent there are a lot of issues
a lot of issues
you know as i get older i have come to
the conclusion that you know there are
certain kinds of problems you don't look
for solutions you look for approaches
and I if you asked me with a wave of the
hands what would be the one thing i
would do to really encourage healthy
sharing because i can understand there's
certain things that need to be withheld
or it makes sense to withhold or at
least limit I would make funding
contingent upon disclosure rules it used
to be just to give you a real world
example it used to be that scientists
medical researchers could publish their
work in the new england journal of
medicine and other medical journals
without disclosing that some of their
research had been financed by
pharmaceutical companies or device
companies for completely understandable
reasons that concealment that
non-disclosure is no longer acceptable I
feel that those same kind of pressures
can be brought to bear to people who
don't check out if you are running a
computer model that predicts the earth
is getting warmer the atmosphere is
getting warmer and it will go up seven
degrees Celsius in the next 50 years
that the oceans will rise the coral will
die I etc show me your code show me the
code I don't want to just see the
equations show me the code because and
I'm saying this as somebody who's
written code I know how you game the
code to kind of put a thumb on the scale
and some of these things are done sub
consciously or unconsciously they have a
saying in the open source development
community many eyes shallow bugs the
more people that see the code the
quicker you spot the bugs and eliminate
them it's good enough a software good
enough for science
there are individuals who are leaders
there are certain fields i think the
royal society in the UK has done a
better job in our own triple-a s of
aggressively and energetically promoting
disclosure and sharing of code that's
not to say that the triple-a s has done
a bad job I actually believe that their
forces there where they're trying to
push for more openness and science but
established institutions particularly
research universities and the tenured
faculty there in I think should step up
they already haven't that they already
do it that the it's really important
that we deal with the premise of your
question many scientists have already
been doing these these things there are
many cultures and subcultures within
science or mentoring and sharing and
helping people out and picking up the
phone or sending you that's that's not
an aberration at all the I'm not asking
people to do things that are inimical to
culture the incentives are oftentimes
ego related and opportunity related
people collaborate because it makes
sense for them to collaborate we should
be promoting free exchange there are
complicating factors if if your school
says if your institution says anything
that you invent while you're on the
faculty is our property not yours or
your compulsory license for that that
creates tensions should it be a 50-50
split an 8020 split what should this
would be so what we're talking about
here are tensions and trade-offs what we
really have to address is what are the
reasonable and rational and fair ways to
manage those trade-offs we're not asking
people to behave abnormally or against
their best interests all policies that
ask people to behave against their best
interest are doomed to fail
again you know it believing as I do in
good governance and democracy I would
like government funding agencies to
insist that taxpayers when our taxes pay
for something when Europeans taxes pay
for something when Asian taxpayers pay
for something that these publicly funded
science funders foundations that they
make it a condition of their funding
that people disclosed in the manner that
makes sense not just the findings but
the code it should be throughout the
value chain of knowledge and discovery
not just black box
no no if people want to if you have
something you know now again this is
turning into an economics kind of
conversation which I'm quite quite
comfortable having if a private you know
here is Apple if Apple versus Google
okay Apple has decided to and Facebook
these these companies have what we would
call call walled gardens they limit the
amount of interoperability and sharing
there's some walls there are some
windows ok Google more of an open-source
kind of thing more p it's easier to
interoperate with with google their
business model is different they want
more eyeballs to sell more advertising
against what you want if you're in the
private sector is what's the reason that
we have to share and collaborate and
this is the classic question what many
organizations have discovered in the
midst the digital revolution is that
it's more profitable it's more
reasonable it's better business to share
not necessarily everything by the way I
don't necessarily want everything shared
I just want to change to use your word I
want two inch anes change the incentive
structures associated with with Sharon I
do not want proprietary to be the
default position I want it to be a
secondary or tertiary default I don't
want it to be the prime option I want it
to be a lower down in the queue option I
want the default to be let's let's err
on the side of being open rather than on
the side of being closed I'll give you a
really good example if I were running
the city of New York if the city of New
York came to me now there's a slight
complication here because of terrorism
sort of issues okay so we have to deal
with but but if the city of New York
came to me and said Michael what's the
fastest best cheapest thing that we
could do to improve transportation in
New York I would say put everything up
online let people be able to run
analytics and observe how the subways
are running how the buses are running
what time's our peak times
for congestion what parts are you have
people figured out clever work arounds
let enable people to have raw data so
they can run simulations and come to you
with proposals for reducing congestion
times doing better link-ups between
trains subways buses etc intermodal
things make it more transparent make
transportation more transparent we'll
call it the trans initiative
absolutely I I think it would be a
fantastic thing if the mayor of New York
currently Mayor Bloomberg who could
bloody well afford it instead of
basically saying nope nobody can go into
times square that there should be the
that would be a great idea the Bloomberg
prize in transportation minimizing
congestion design constraints for
improving quality of Transportation and
quality of life because there is such a
thing as perverse outcomes I'll tell you
a true story in that regard for reasons
I won't bore you with I became an expert
in the history of traffic lights it is a
true story that New York for almost two
years tried to economize on traffic
lights by eliminating the amber light
they got rid of the middle light and
they went from red and green because
they would save it would save money was
cleaners binary let's just say that the
accident rate went up rather
significantly so always you've got to
come to grips with the notion that
transportation isn't just about cars and
streets it's an ecosystem that deals
with people you know people watching
this probably it's worth their time
looking at Tom Vanderbilt's book on
traffic because traffic is as much a
story of human behavior as it is about
technological innovation prizes that
come up with clever ways of aligning
human behavior and technical
technological innovation great idea
fully supportive
you